welcome back to cbs this morning
there is disturbing new video of what
happened before the death of george
floyd at the hands of police
a warning these images are distressing
this footage is from the body camera of
former minneapolis officer
tau it shows how a crowd gathered as
floyd was held down
many people repeatedly asked officers to
check his pulse
boy's death is linked to a troubling
reality about encounters with law
enforcement
on average black men and women are five
times more likely to be stopped by
police without good reason
than white people
videos like these of unarmed black
people being arrested with excessive
force
have become all too common and raise
questions about whether police treatment
of african americans
is marked by systemic racism this
officer already had it in his mind there
was going to be
a physical encounter because i did
nothing to encourage it nothing to
revoke it even tennis star james blake
once ranked fourth in the world was not
immune to the disparate treatment of
black men by cops
when i leave the tennis world i go back
to being just a black man
and that means if i put a hoodie on and
i go out for a run i'm a suspect
in 2015 blake was forcibly taken down by
an nypd officer
while standing outside of a new york
city hotel
in a case of mistaken identity and i
wasn't even
mistaken for a violent criminal the
person he was looking for was someone
that was
making credit card fraud and instead of
me running or or me fighting
if that had been the the case i have a
feeling he would have made it a whole
lot worse
it's been five years are you still
living with this
the physical scars are gone but mentally
for sure and
every time i get pulled over or i get
stopped or i'm around
police i'm a little more nervous and
with the fact that now i realize
how little accountability there is for
them to abuse their power
i'm nervous i'm scared the fear blake
experiences today as a result of that
incident
is just one of the long-term effects of
racism
well racism is a trauma it's just as
much of a trauma as
combat rape assault life
in and of itself is living in a war zone
dr monica williams has studied racial
trauma for much of her career
and says a starting point for change is
a simple one
understanding what racism is
for most white people a racism is a
white supremacist or somebody running
around burning crosses
the bigger problem is that our whole
culture operates under an umbrella of
white supremacy
we have racist outcomes even without
individual people doing racist things
anthropology professor mark mccoy is
tackling that notion head on
at any point in your life would you have
described yourself as a racist
you know have i have i had racist
thoughts i'm sure
i don't think you get to grow up and and
be white in america
and not have those things and have blind
spots
mccoy tweeted about his white privilege
drawing parallels to the incident with
george floyd
who was initially detained by
minneapolis police
for allegedly spending a counterfeit
twenty dollar bill
i spent the night in jail i was received
six months probation
and that was the end of it for floyd it
was a death sentence
why do you believe the outcome was so
different i think it comes down to
viewing people of color as humans their
humanity
one of the roles of the police is of
course to police our society in a way
that is
fair and we don't have that system
until you can't statistically tell the
difference between my children
everybody else's children and we have a
problem it's a system that for decades
disproportionately protects white
americans
like tampa bay race pitcher colin poche
it was pretty shocking to think that you
know maybe my appearance was different
you know my
my outcome could have been pretty
similar to his poche says when he was 12
years old
the same age as tamir rice he too
was caught by police playing with the
toy gun
you know a cop drove down the street he
gave us a five minute talk and you know
went on with his day
and you know i couldn't help but you
know just notice the differences
and similarities in our stories the
difference was a fatal one
rice was shot and killed by a cleveland
police officer
in 2014. a lot of these conversations
are uncomfortable but
you know that's these are the kind of
talks you have to have to try to get
that hate out of the system
we're not looking to be treated better
than anyone else
just equality equality shouldn't feel
like a step down for white america it's
not taking away from anything they've
done right now but it just
it's time for it to change and there are
people who still deny
these similarities but when you see it
in black and white
right same instance same
description but different outcomes yeah
that james blake video is just startling
every time i see it
yeah it really is really exciting and i
always tell people
you have to keep in mind that you go
after vulnerable communities
those vulnerable vulnerable communities
are just the canary and the coal mines
for
the rest of society it can happen to you
too eventually so
stop it nip it in the bud the video is
there